hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Tekken 7 is the end of the Mishima blood
feud so I thought now is the right time
to recap and retell the story from
Tekken 1 to Tekken 7 I won't be looking
at many other characters outside the
Mishima so if you're looking for a story
of Paul Phoenix or martial law then this
isn't the video for you but if you want
to know about the origin to the devil
gene all the way running through the
series then this is it let's do this I'm
going to do it in chronological order so
Tekken 7 will bookend all the other
games this is going to be a confusing
affair so grab the popcorn open your
mind and let's figure this out
the story picks up with heihachi mishima
in his family dojo training in their
fighting style his father jinpachi is a
world-renowned fighter and the head of
the Mishima Zaibatsu when translated
into English that means a huge Japanese
business grew through one day a young
girl shows up at Kim patchi's dojo and
begins training alongside Heihachi
her name is Kazumi Hachi Joe I am so
sorry if I'm pronouncing this wrong by
the way
as time passed they became friends and
as they grew older their love blossomed
and their son Kazuya was born a few
years later Kazuma collapsed during
training and he actually tended to her
things did not look good for her
miraculously Kazumi survived and went
about her business as if nothing
happened but he actually knew something
had changed sometime later consumed his
real intentions were exposed Kazumi
reveals she came to the Mishima dojo to
watch and finally kill Hitachi for the
tyrant he was destined to become the to
fought and Kazuma travailed
the devil gene complete with blaming
butterfly winds and devil horns so no -
no cover
hey Hachi prevails and murders the look
of his life shedding it here after he
breaks his wife's neck
what a lovely moment hey yeah he took
his five-year-old son to the top of a
cliff and told him of his mother's fate
come on a better house a lot kazuya's
rage was no match for hey Hachi
so had already planned to kill his dog
just in case II had the devil gene like
his mother
the plan was simple raka do you offer
cliff if Kazuya died then he didn't have
the devil gene but if he survived and
somehow climbed back up the cliff then
he must be part devil heihachi's
character changed dramatically after the
Kazuma fight and he's now fixated on
power and strength he even imprisoned
his own father jinpachi and takes
command of the Mishima Zaibatsu Jin
patches caught remains under the family
dojo forty years later after many years
of building wealth and power hey Hachi
longs for the old days of fighting in
martial arts competition and decides to
start the tournament to be known as the
king of Iron Fist or just Iron Fist of
Tekken for short
he puts off a huge first for the winner
and enters the tournament himself as do
many fighters around the world including
Nina Williams dressed as a street hooker
oh and guess who else enters in secret
it's only bloody Kazuya who did indeed
survive his fall from the cliff and he's
now a little bit pissed and ready for
revenge guess who makes it to the final
yes it's father versus son hey Hachi
versus Kazuya the to beat came back the
south of each other but Kazuya emerges
victorious and decides to throw his dad
from the same cliff he was flung off as
a boy
[Music]
with hey Hachi presumed dead Kazuya
inherits the Mishima Zaibatsu and runs
it for a few years until it gets a bit
bored and announces Tekken 2 but this
time instead of a financial award for
the winner they would indeed take
control of the Mishima Zaibatsu it's
sellable the tournament was entered by a
record amount of people including Jun
Kazama who will be keep this storyline
very soon as if you weren't expecting it
but pops hey Hachi who survived his fall
from the cliff and he's now at the
revenge over Kazuya under the cost
desires his beloved company back during
the tournament Kazuya and yon find time
to get down and dirty together resulting
in Jon falling pregnant but we'll get to
that in Tekken 3 in a repeat of the
Tekken 1 final both Heihachi and Kazuya
make it with the roles reversed they'll
actually wins this fight which causes
kazuya's dormant devil gene to activate
just as his mother's did years ago hey
happy knew this would happen and is
fully prepared defeating the devil
version of his son winning the
tournament and regaining the Mishima
Zaibatsu to make sure Kazuya and his
devil gene are gone for good this time
he decides not to throw him off a cliff
again but this time tosses his flesh and
blood into an active volcano
[Music]
definitely a candidate for dad of the
year remember Jun Kazama yeah the one
who did the dirty deed with Kazuya well
she had a son Jin but decided to keep
him in the Kazama clan in the hopes of
keeping him out of the Mishima blood
feud Jin is trained in because I'm a
fighting style which his mother mastered
Jun suddenly feels a disturbance kind is
like a Jedi and feels the presence of
ogre a god of fighting who was recently
released from its tomb and who do you
think let augur out none other than
Heihachi Mishima and his Tekken forces
who are looking for sources of power
around the globe
Olga kills Joon although that is not
100% confirmed but her son survives
still in his teens jin travels to find
his grandfather in the hopes of training
to fight olga and avenge his mother
Heihachi agrees and four years later Jin
has mastered the Mishima karate
[Music]
hey Hachi announces the third Tekken
tournament in which he hopes to capture
Olga and somehow absorb his power you
know with gene splicing or something
like that basically his thirst for power
is now unquenchable and Olga's ultimate
power is next on his list second three
had its share of weird and wonderful
characters - including a 2-foot dinosaur
called Gong but let's pretend that
didn't happen
moving on Jin beat the living piss out
of everyone until his mother's killer
appears ogre offers up a good fight but
a revenge Bill chin comes out victorious
even ogre second forms true ogre
couldn't defeat Jin who has now avenged
his beloved mother out of nowhere
Heihachi
and his Tekken force is gunned down Jin
and killed him
[Music]
why do you take actually do this
potentially in fear of his empire being
taken by his grandson or maybe his
knowledge of the devil gene caused this
reaction but that ends up being a bad
idea
jinns devil gene activates and after
some mild vengeance he flies away
[Music]
hey Thad she continues to search for Jin
until he accidentally finds the corpse
of his son Kazuya instead his remains
are being held at G corporation a
biogenetic company looking to resurrect
Kazuya as the Tekken force is arrived at
G cop it is revealed Kazuya is not only
a live but is stronger than ever
we shoot
[Music]
ha boogers didn't stand a chance
hey Hach she decides another Tekken
tournament the fourth in fact will
attract a zoo Yahoo is now fully focused
on revenge again and maybe this could
also see Jin return to who we know can't
turn down a good old scrap summer color
saluting you as expected anyone who is
anyone has joined the tournament with
favorite jin kazama here to murder any
Mishima he can get his hands on that
anger fueling his devil gene sees him
reach the finals where he should face
father Kazuya but he is attacked by
Tekken bosses who subdue and drugged him
hey Hachi attempts to mentally and
physically brutalized Jin in the hopes
of acquiring his power nuclear
[Laughter]
my oh my
the orbiter gin first defeat his father
you win oh and just as he's about to
kill his grandfather he has a vision
his mother John is still keeping tabs on
gin and convinces him not to give in to
the dark side hang on this dialogue him
gin once again flies away sparing both
his father and grandfather
suddenly a fleet of jacks are said to
destroy the Mishima's granular jock
fighting side-by-side Kazuya and
Heihachi fight off the onslaught
until Kazuya leave his father to fight
alone during the Jack eunuch explode
killing hey Hachi and burying his body
in his own dojo Heihachi Mishima is dead
an unknown individual takes over the
Mishima Zaibatsu and establishes another
inés this tournament Tekken 5 Kazuya
decides to accept the invitation as this
is a way to find out who was in charge
of design but su and G cop to Phil he
believed sent those Jacky units to try
and kill him and his father as the
tournament begins jinpachi mishima is
revealed as the organizer if you
remember right at the start of the story
jinpachi was imprisoned by his son hey
Hachi and left to die for 40 years under
the Mishima dojo which we just saw blow
poke as the tournament begins jinpachi
reveals he is fighting internally with
the devil spirit who is controlling him
with it with his last breath of humanity
jinpachi started this tournament in the
folks that someone could defeat him and
stop his impending reign of destruction
we've come a long way from throwing
five-year-olds off cliffs haven't we
jian easily reaches the final and face
it his great-grandfather at this point
jin is so powerful even a devil present
writing legend has no chance and
jinpachi is finally laid to rest
ghin takes his place as the head of the
Mishima Zaibatsu he's now completely
controlled by power just like his father
grandfather and great-grandfather
Jen does the unthinkable and declares
independence from the world don't ask me
how that works but he starts World War 3
remember when he was just a nice young
man
well I blamed puberty the only
organization big enough to fight the
Mishima Zaibatsu is decock who have also
grown exponentially last Alexander
Sion's the fight a field leader in the
zaibatsu is tight he cannot stand by and
changes his allegiance in order to stop
the war he's in love with an Android by
the way - sorry we follow him slowly
uncovering information with help from a
Wesley Snipes wannabe Raven as the world
virals into a war on depression again
announces the six-second tournament
which attracts another but ton of
fighters as well as Kazuya and the
attentions of a hat wait didn't he get
flaunted pieces
oh well video game logic during this
storyline Lars is revealed to be
heihachi's illegitimate son we also
previously discovered that Lee is hey
hatches adopted son and asker Kazama is
somehow related to Jin this family tree
is ridiculous anyway back to the story
Jin has been using the dybbuks whose
resources to research the devil gene and
finds that an ancient being named Azazel
is the original host if he can find a
way to wake him he could wipe the devil
gene from existence thus freeing himself
how do you know that
and for me how does he do this he starts
that world war we've been talking about
he's really a nice guy and although he's
prepared to kill millions of innocent
people his hearts in the right place
right the devil is defeated by Lars and
fake blade and reveals he is the being
that wiped out humanity if they become
too evil pretty much forcing humanity to
start again if they lose compassion for
one another of course the next thing as
basil does itself is gross
[Music]
luckily everyone we care about escaped
unharmed Jin arrived and proclaimed as
evil is not yet dead and only someone
with the devil gene can defeat that big
chicken
Thursday's all right on cue breaks from
the debris
[Music]
[Music]
see
a bolt of light explodes from the pitch
and Jin is seemingly dead alongside
Azazel Nina tries to make Jin sound like
a good guy but we all know he's a bit of
a [ __ ] chin put everything he had into
this one moment it's not for me to judge
if he was right or wrong a short time
later Raven finds Jin who still bears
the devil symbol indicating he still has
the devil gene and his efforts were
futile he is contained and taken into
custody with Jin out of the picture hey
Hachi returns to full strength and
forcefully takes back desire but su at
the same time Kazuya sees his full
control of G [ __ ] and the war rages on
back over to Jin in the Middle East
after he wakes he doesn't take too
kindly to being restrained and explodes
in anger killing everyone in the
helicopter he runs from the United
Nations only to be saved by Uncle Lars
who still fancies that sex robot but we
don't talk about that okay hey Hachi has
just finished rebuilding the Mishima
dojo and enjoy some R&R when the street
fighter franchise decide to enter the
frame Akuma an old friend of hey hatches
wife Kazumi has come for revenge but
doesn't give any more details
just as the fight is optical Kazuya
sends a battalion of jacks to crash the
party they don't last long but he gets
to see Akuma and hey Hachi battle a coma
win and hey hatchet is reported dead
again I don't know about you but I'm not
buying it this time Akuma then vows to
kill Kazuya still finds that quite
amusing those children do the Tekken
force is launched an attack on violet
systems where Jin is recovering was not
unsuccessful thankfully Lars and that
sex robot we don't talk about they even
go as far as collapsing their research
facility on Nina Williams she's okay
though
she's about us this could be interesting
to watch Kazuya see that a tumor has
reached G cop and called off all his
guards so they can fight man to man or
devil to demon or whatever the heck they
are Kazuya is forced to become devil
Kazuya due to Akuma superior ability
allowing hey Hachi to show the world who
he really is
death by media I think they call that to
make matters worse Heihachi uses a
satellite laser to blow up G cop and
kill Kazuya and Akuma
Green is a survive possibility well did
the detective in retaliation kazooie
uses his devil beam to bring down the
satellite crashing back down to earth
killing many innocent people the public
see that that is a Mishima logo and
everyone blames hey Hachi again it's
similar or cooler in things are about to
heat up I'll say had she traveled to a
volcano to fight Kazuya one last time
that fight is a brilliant run sir
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
an epic battle of the ages which swings
back and forth
Kazuya powered by his hatred defeats his
father
[Music]
the only way to end this saga is to
throw your father into molten lava okay
to saying when you don't sit on a
tapioca so red okay
is this the end of the epic power
struggle and blood Butte Akuma tries to
ruin the touching family moment but
Kazuya is on to his son we refer you to
another epic battle raided but we are
unsure who wins under credits roll after
those credits we finally see Djinn back
to full health he vows to kill Kazuya
and undo his terrible act so after all
that this isn't the end of the story
give it seven more years and we'll have
Tekken eight good good enough cool we
did it the entire Mishima story from
Tekken I don't know about you but I need
a later home I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade please give us a life I really
think I've earned it this time it's been
emotional I'll see you next time
satellite or saying we need OG renate
Toluca so ray together